The Prodigy frontman Keith Flint has
died at the age of 49 famous fries and
hits including firestarter how to space
breathe was found this morning his home
in Essex a Keith band formed the band
prodigy in 1990 along with producer Liam
Howlett they met in a nightclub
it couldn't became one of Britain's most
popular electronic music groups
the band had just announced of a
headline a music festival in Norway this
summer let's bring in the broadcast from
TJ able to do the joins us from crackled
in Northwest London Edward welcome to
you might 49 I'm short when I got the
message I grew up listening to the
prodigy I remember when I wasn't
supposed to go when I was 13 and 14 went
to my mates parties and they be blaring
out everybody's in the place you'll love
all those kind of iconic rave anthems
and I think The Prodigy were there at
the time with rave culture which bornus
it kind of cemented together nurse it
was kind of people-powered so the youth
generation and the prodigy were part of
there and I mean they did lates of
tracks like breve and all their album
all their albums were just seminal and
iconic I mean if anyone who's an
original rainbow who went out to a club
for a festival and danced their apology
record like me today it's going to be
such a very sad and song full time I
mean he was 49 and you know I never got
the chance to meet him but in terms of
their music and kind of his legacy it's
incredible I mean fire starts I mean
it's the way the fact reduced what one
thing which was unique about Geetha and
what the prodigy always did they were
consistent and they changed their sound
then whether you're 20 or whether you're
15 those old brave those who tore them
back in the day in X can the palace
wherever they were out and about they
can always remember the good times they
certainly was an ambassador to the rape
culture yeah and if you just obscure
your microphone there but you're sort of
coming into magic for the factors to
Skype but
i justit's like six number one albums
which tells its own story of consistency
over the years I suppose yeah very
consistently and I think one good thing
about what the prodigy were they were
they weren't they were an underground
act to start off with and then they
crossed over and they they kind of
related so everybody in in the in the
country all ages and most importantly
all Ravens and yeah I'm still in shock
can't believe we're talking about it
well it also as well when we flashed up
his image you know this is the 1990s to
actually project a look which is unique
to him not unless you're looking at now
but some of the others I mean that just
as a feat of presentation it's quite
something to pull off yeah no of course
I mean that iconic look and I suppose
it's kind of that rebellious streak of
I'm gonna be Who I am and I'm gonna have
that look which Bay being sort of
society on mainstream may not like but
he did it and he didn't conform and I
think that's what was unique about him
and then the prodigy they've been
conforming when you hear their tracks is
it's whether it's raging as those
baselines it's it kind of sort of
conjures up what I suppose sort of they
were in a cordon but the Sex Pistols of
the rave culture that influential
definitely definitely I mean in terms of
what they did I mean for me going back
to growing up and listening to their
tracks your love everybody in the face
Charlie says breathe and I mean that
they've even collaborated they did a
trap with Kula shaker which was out of
this world their thing was in the Ryan I
think in 1997 it was like wow is that is
that how they can kind of progress and
take their sound I mean certainly
leaders in electronic music